we got the secret Invasion trailer we got the
Blue Beetle trailer we got the Spider-Man across
the spider-verse trailer now we got the one that
we know the citizens of the reject Nation have
really been waiting for but before that today's
video is sponsored by enthusiasm ourselves
trailer and it's a teaser trailer numero dos I
can't wait I am so intrigued ladies and gentlemen
leave a like would you come
on Johnny let's go party
Land There It Is confirmation
it's gonna remain walking
hi Barbie what's up hi Ken
hi Ken hi Ken
uh I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're girlfriend boyfriend you do what
I'm actually not sure
it's so funny
earnest
wow
yeah
he's doing here I'm coming with you
did you bring your rollerblades I
literally go nowhere without them
ah looks like this beach is a little
too much Beach for you can if I wasn't
severely injured I would beat you off
right now oh no beach off with you any
day Ken anyone who wants to beach him
off has to beat me off first I will
beat both of you off at the same time
nobody's gonna beat anyone off hahaha
oh my most anticipated movie of the
year it's gonna be a treat we gotta
think about this for just a second guys we got
to think about our journey of how amazing this
looks first we hear about a Barbie movie and
you're like I know what this is going to be
warm rotors whatever and then suddenly you hear
about who's directing it and you go okay that's
bid odd that person brings a lot of nuance and
layers to their movies first like Cinema then
you hear about who's who's gonna be starring and
Ryan Gosling as Ken then you see the trailer and
it's 2001 it's face obviously with toys and
you see a second trailer and it's nothing
like the first trailer yeah and they still
don't even really tell you what the plot
is based off of a plot that supposedly was
like put I don't know if it's a leak I don't
know if it's confirmed it seems like that's
what's present here in the trailer Barbie is
living in Barbie land a bunch of Barbies it
looks amazing and she has to venture off to
the real world the one rumor is that because she
has some imperfections but then she discovers in
the real world that I don't know some [__]
about like comes from a perfectionism exists
you know perfect being all your life now here we
are that trailer was brilliant to me watching what
Ryan Gosling is doing here especially because
he's talked about how he's essentially said
Ken's a loser I don't know if he said those exact
words but he said that several times and no one
wants to play with Ken there's sort of this
self-deprecating way of how he's talked about
the treatment of Ken and this trailer leans into
that out of all the Kents seems like he's the one
who gets the short in the stick he's a little
bit dumb he's a little bit naive Barbie doesn't
seem that into him and he he seems a bit like a
loser in this trailer I love it well it seems like
they're leading into that yeah like he's like kind
of like a petty Jealous Guy especially around all
the other kids it seems like him and see milio
especially are just gonna have like a constant
back and forth game of one upsmanship always going
down the Lego movie has been a touchstone for this
in the past but I love the way that they imbue
that sort of innocence of how you would play
with the dolls like Barbie and Ken come with a
domestic sort of suggested lifestyle that also is
like completely innocuous in the hands of a child
so I love that whole thing about like you want to
come over spend the night and do what I don't know
yeah you know yeah it's like it's so innocent but
it's also clearly knowing what we're all thinking
in the back of its mind and so there's this you
know interesting medicine Sheen about it which
I think is very fitting for the here and now
and also for again you know I think Barbie has to
be unless we're talking straight to DVD a little
smarter you know than it appears on the outside
and I think the new log line is something about
like you're a perfect being in a perfect world
unless you're having an existential crisis or
you're a Ken so Barbie existential crisis and
then Ken yeah yeah and he seems like he's a big
co-dependent on her and I think having uh this an
inappropriate naativity irreverent sexual humor
is really fitting for Barbie you know because of
especially the kind of conversations that have
circulated around Barbie and a lot of the kind
of what I mean hopefully no real little kids are
watching this trailer reaction but you know I I
especially growing up the little I remember being
kids and you'd hear about like hey you're taking a
poor button doesn't have any body parts yeah yeah
absolutely and then they're making these jokes
about like beats you off and stuff or even just
like little things of like her feet just staying
in that position because they're always shaped
to be in high heels designed for Tarantino it was
Tarantino's dream come to life right look out and
speaking of dream this looks like a dream I love
the production design of this oh sure these colors
pop it is wonderfully Vivid so imaginative and
I just noticed the Wizard of Oz imagery at the
movie theater in the background which is perfect
for this fantasy Wonderland that we are stepping
into right now this looks so cool well there's so
many like cameos as other Barbies and things like
that and even Will Ferrell back as Lord Business
yeah with her having the elf-like movie plot yeah
exactly like this is fascinating to me too because
you know the time in which Barbie would have been
introduced as a toy just in culture in general is
also a time where you don't you know necessarily
acknowledge as many adult things as we do now
so I wonder if that's gonna play into this too
well you know one thing it sounds a little weird
to say Ryan Gosling you know let's we gotta face
facts here I'm in love with Ryan Gosling every
everyone should know this about me I'm absolutely
in love with this man I would leave everyone I'd
slaughter a village of children if it meant get
him to spend the rest of my life with Ryan Gosling
that's true what does it say about Ryan Gosling
who's willing to spend the rest of his life with
a guy who would slaughter a village of children
that means he thinks about his heart first that's
right he just knows when someone's gonna matter
about his past actions he would care about who
I am today as long as you love me baby I don't
care who you are where you're from or what you did
but he's he's older now he's a much older person
and everyone else they cast here is looks like
aesthetically very very young young Ryan Gosling
you could tell like he's he's a much older guy now
and I wonder if they're going to lean into that
in some way with Ken or are they just gonna have
him I don't know if they're what they really deal
with age in this movie if anybody needs to be able
to accept Aging in Hollywood it's men no I'm not
going but you know what I mean Ryan Gosling does
not look like as young as a lot of the other cast
members who are living in Barbie land he does come
across like a guy trying to appear younger than he
actually is yeah sure and the way that like even
though it's like it's part of the aesthetic the
very sort of distinct color palette like even his
hair just kind of looks like an old guy trying to
be young he he looks like the villain in the first
Blade Runner movie yeah you have tears and rain
I love the sets I love how uh you can tell
a lot of like the matte painting wallpaper
backgrounds for a lot of it and a lot of it
looks like real buildings as well I think
yeah fake waves and stuff like yeah the artifice
is great they did an exceptional job here sure
um I can't wait for that yeah this feels like
it's going to be a very meta film but also have
some type of sociological sociological yeah sure
why not social commentary yeah socio-political
paleontology commentary that's right it's
gonna answer some Cosmic questions for us
the meaning of life all right guys well leave
your thoughts down below this movie looks like
an absolute blast of a time what did you
think subscribe hey let's send this with a
Tyler Hague we could shout out a woman today
but I said no who really reminds me of a doll
I'd want to own and play with oh sure you
I would love to have a doll of you Tyler
and just stretch you out
like in the split positions
put you with another doll and be like hi I'm
Tighter and then I I'm also Tyler oh my God I
have a secret cursive uh homosexuality only with
myself yes I will I would only want to be gay for
me it's the age of God and have you two make out
these two Tyler dolls but then oh no a woman comes
into this correct no oh my God what do I do oh no
but am I gay or for myself or do I love this wolf
this is a real American drama it's all good
this is beautiful shout out of the year keep
going I want to see this movie that that would
be the Tyler Hague story yeah really would that
be that would be the best I mean we should mass
produce these dolls so that people can know the
joys too gay for yourself you should be or do
you follow true love in the header way which
one is it going to be just be Polly for yourself
and your your true uh baby love that would be so
interesting what a weird Twisted Netflix show
that would be about your life of like what if
what if like they were married like he's married
but then he falls in love with a clone of himself
and then it's like why why is she jealous why is
the wife jealous it's just just another reason
there's no difference between the two if you
love me you should love him fake story this
was a test you failed I want a divorce all righty
well thank you guys love you Tyler love you Tyler